all right so I don't know exactly what
you mean in your question
think you mean this
month
so you're going to do tensionage and the
guy pulls your arm down and you're
scared pulling my arm
okay
maybe you're a little more dynamic
pretty cool pulling that arm okay
the reason why that's happening is
you're throwing him under you
you do not throw the person under you
you never throw them under you okay
unless you want to but then you should
follow up with a Stomp or something like
that okay but nagit was that always
projects now you waza projects okay and
so what's happening is is you are
generating the kazushi part
and then doing this throw
you must project so when you project
boom you must project okay it doesn't
matter where you're touching you must
project so he comes in here boom you
must reject I just went from him
grabbing me to his forearm okay so same
thing here this throw doesn't go huge
even if I bring him it I'm going to
bring him in
caught his Landing
okay so what happened is I remember on
your video we were working on bringing
the Uka in that's good that's a first
step but after you make contact with him
you have to project him out okay so I
watched the video and you were working
on the first part bring him in
loading him on your hips
but you have to once you make contact
it's gonna be here
on the arm
really what you're doing is taking this
adhesion part
and moving it to this adhesion part and
this part with the arm
his hand
this is what projects out
that's what you're trying to do
so
I'm over here
let me show you where he's landing on me
I project him out
okay let's try it
remember
and if you're doing this thing
is going that way
I didn't get project him okay when when
I go here
[Music]
he's walking that way
got it so you don't go here he has
balance and then you're doing what you
think is projection
he has to fall that way okay
then maybe from this angle
this arm
is going to do kotagash with his head
so if I have put the gas here
this arm is going to go that way
that way back around this way
you can do it with someone's head this
way this way
now you do it with one arm
so you can sphere
this is gonna go this way this way
it's just very very tiny
but it's not
is this
that's not it you're going to on this
end
you're going to adhere
and here to here and a little circle in
but he's already following that way that
just helps
so whoo wow
add your footwork is
even better so my footwork comes out
I move in
ouch
foreign
okay
let's try